au port de la goulette c'est une
livraison vécue comme un soulagement est
perçu comme l'aboutissement d'un projet
humanitaire entre la cuisine et la
france quatre ambulances chargé de
respirateurs de concentrateurs d'oxygène
et pas moins de 28 mille masques ffp2
quitte enfin les services de la douane
tunisienne après un voyage de plus de 24
heures depuis auxerre dans l'yonne elles
sont enfin là pour le plus grand bonheur
de silane fils du docteur djemaa médecin
franco tunisien et initiateur du projet
alors assuré bien sûr ça fait des heures
on attend devant le port que que la
marchandise elle sort les ambulances et
tout le matériel là on est rassuré tout
est là y'a rien n'a été touché la douane
a été super gentils nous ont laissé
faire ce qu'on voulait on perd il a
beaucoup travaillé en france pour sortir
tout ce matériel donc là vraiment on est
super content tout est là et on va
rendre heureux le peuple tunisien avant
que tout ce matériel soit distribué dans
le gouvernorat de nabeul le convoi
humanitaire doit passer par le ministère
de la santé passage obligatoire pour
régler les dernières formalités
administratives
ce matin dans le village d'ennemis da
1h30 de tunis quelques villageois se
sont réunis autour du maire et du
président de l'association faire du bien
aux autres partenaires de ce projet
humanitaire devant le dispensaire du
village la joie se lit sur les visages
c'est au son des sirènes et floqué du
drapeau tunisien que deux des quatre
ambulances font leur entrée sous les
applaudissements de l'assemblée un
convoi précieux qui va permettre de
soulager le personnel soignant de cette
région agricole qui compte pas moins de
trente mille habitants une véritable
bouffée d'oxygène pour béchir bourguiba
merde delmi da pour qui ces dons vont
permettre d'améliorer l'autonomie des
collectivités locales et en diminuer la
dépendance vis-à-vis des métropoles
c'est un geste généreux de la part d
des français ont vis-à-vis des tunisiens
et surtout vis-à-vis d'elle hmida
spécialement on a un besoin énorme vu
qu'on n'a pas un hôpital local
qui peut subvenir aux besoins des
citoyens ce qui nous a poussé à faire
des rois la relation avec nos amis en
france l'arrivée de ces dons ont changé
pas mal de choses à enfidha les gens
étaient contents d'avoir tous ces
matches ce matériel là et ils sont
contents d'avoir les moyens de transport
pour aller voir et les médecins du
voisinage en pleine crise sanitaire et
dans un contexte d'instabilité politique
des centaines de bénévoles issus de la
diaspora ont multiplié les initiatives
citoyennes des projets qui ont permis de
combler les lacunes d'un gouvernement en
crise très critiqué pour sa gestion de
l'épidémie en pleine quatrième vague le
pays a enregistré pas moins de 100 à 150
décès par jour duo co-lead soit le taux
de mortalité le plus élevé du continent
africain grâce à la solidarité
internationale ambulance matériel
médical ou encore vaccin acheminé au
moins permis de soulager les services
médicaux tunisien